en
français ça soir on sort
c'est cela qui
me la crise je dois cuit ouais tu te
fasses cuir tout cas oui la pizza non
pas la piste rapide si tu la prends je
les vends les pythies moitié fou
contient un chapitre chef jeunes
accueillis
à benne ont maintenant tu manques tu
m'as puis mais je peux te livrer
bon bien dit s'il vous plaît ou demain
ça s'il vous plaît pour la piste demain
je fais au
haut tu crois ou ici à la prise à la
piste comment on lapide les gars avaient
des mots d'espoir aux
caisses qui ont bien vieilli château
allait réinstaller quoi tu veux quoi tu
penses et mer on peut quoi faire allez
arrêter offrant tapissé va t'en
aller dépêche-toi j'ai faim vois tu dis
que je te vois ouais
c'est pas un frisbee
owen on joue pas que la nourrice yeux
allez quoi où je dois aller soit sympa
attend rapide je dois fais pas tu veux
une [ __ ] je te refais vu m'a fait moins
une jeunesse est fraîche fraîche ouais
je paye pas j'ai pas d'argent tu peux te
les changes voilà ses chances c'est là
les restos du coeur ici aux cours
actuels tapis statues fait que tapie tu
es tu veux quoi aussi tu vois vraiment
lui une piquante
aller vite j'ai faim
les goûts
[Musique]
le fou rire
mais en plus tu dis que mes pizzas sont
pas bonnes tu pas d'éclater pas bonne
j'ai des qualités j'ai été malade
c'était maladroit et pourquoi tu étais
malade je sais pas un petit truc pas
ferait peut-être tous tes frères ici
tout ça tient avec la peintre insa temps
je m'énerve ou quoi pourquoi pas tant
et puis le mois
au hi fi ou autre je boirai
foot c'est la pizza occupe toi et tes
voyages peuvent pas parce qu'il ya du
chorizo ça pique mais je m'en fous et
sega sega
[Musique]